during week 8 of the 2017 LPK summer
split we saw crowds get a last-minute
pentakill against Africa freak Samsung
will complete it they're going to go for
it can they find it a couple more when
thanks from crowd tick finish this one
I'll be so tacky
buddy kale kale over to crowd the 2-0 so
I thought it's thinking which pentakill
is the best of them all
here are our picks for the top 10 best
Penta kills of all time coming in 10 is
c9 Bulls agenda against fnatic during
the 2015 World Championship together
both stinky is out to the turtle line
for the gonna be careful a big [ __ ]
figure that's the killers of ricotta the
beer goes down as well when the Ducks
are coming through a double kill purple
a triple kill holy cow holy cow that's
what these are picking Darius cloud tied
at three members arrives
Citarella Soria still alive they are
undefeated in the World Championship and
clouds on are 3 and 0
our ninth spot goes to so ad and his
game-changing Penta against Blackpool
during the 2015 world's quarterfinals go
for it
yes they don't walk in which Miffy right
now amazing would have an unfair - - but
he's been dead so this is in vision of a
platform I love collabs they got a big
amazing can jump over the wall who is
going to win this fight and getting the
grant team that goes origin here's the
battle Karsa alone in front of absorbing
gets done so as his arm Lawrence I post
as
is still going he's don't forget the
Thursdays on his gills across he gets
some damage on his day
they thought
to stake the game so to get out there
Barry
that's how you win again grabbing the
eighth spot is tsm's wild turtle and his
pentakill during his first game in the
na LCS really want to win too much crap
patron that numbers take the bit of
damage but they've got this thing how
they could go for this one beresan front
cyrus thank you very low loud one is
still yet to use gives us that momi
there it is he goes now crescendo hit
the entire complexity though can they
turn it around while third ladder back
just hitting hitting one after the other
there's a double girlfriend someone is
Josie that's gonna beat him a triple
kill em I ain't done that's going to be
a Quadra kill
can he get a path to go front you 101
it's going to be the path take care
folks beautiful by wall self stepping up
camp you have something to answer right
now because your replacement is doing a
fantastic job stealing the seventh spot
is reckless his memorable Penta against
og during Game three of a 2015 u LCS
summer finals give all sorts of shadows
so let's ride the lantern out and these
jerks promise ya we'll keep the tower
alive rain ever was in trouble there
goes yellow star another taut amazingly
Missy Wild Rose will slow them down slip
the loss connects as well and reckless
first sucks that secure government
that's a double he's looking for the
girl at the triple he's looking for four
that's the quad right he will get it to
reset forward looking for a pentakill
we're here
Joe record is on fire today jumping
forward he gets it guilty wind surprise
coming in sixth is doublelift jinx Penta
against TSM during the 2015 na LCS
summer finals to get to the right
position to be in the right spot Zach
Hill going to them but dyrus has also
fallen that's going to be Bulldogs are
going down we are way too close now for
CLG triple kill for turtle looking for
the Quadra is not going to get it that
time it's a triple for double if he's
looking for Pearson Joe came on it
nowhere and it look like the fight was
going to turn on TSM side but double if
the whole time was free hitting our
fifth spot go to easyhoon and his
incredible base defense to turn the game
around looking for long doesn't have any
damage to probably this one up first
Nexus heart under fire is he's trying to
go long is going to die is now dandy
turns up this big Oakland is going to
fall caveman can he get in there ways
way no doubt of the will cavemen will we
do an easier to any be the hero takes
down icon SMLC it's getting rid of dandy
flushes easy hurt any to any toys again
and she young now going to try and find
him zhonya's comes through to avoid ear
Kathy and surprised and now be she after
a pentakill for easier in the end their
Nexus she's going to fall down and OMG
definitely made them work for it
making the list for the second time SS
grabs the fourth spot with his legendary
all-star Penta
back in 2013
sealing the third spot is in 2nf penta
during the 2014 world quarterfinals
against TSM will be a lockdown
intervention comes out nicely from
looper is it enough though wildturtle
takes down modest that the double kill
coming in for him they start to clean up
this fight but now they're all spread
out in the wrong position another answer
coming in from bjergsen
but they have lost four members and he's
trying to run by itself great tempest
the [ __ ] actually does blocks out
fearsome just arrange to fight
[Applause]
coming in second is that series-winning
pentas during Game five of the 2015 LPL
spring finals ladies so close an icon
for support like sleeve up going back in
a cone around the fibers death finally
makes me think I'd be getting tanked up
a Sox will have actually died this one
goes back you know makers not here in
depth now peel the way bokura does so
much work in the fact Roman it might not
be enough it boss needs Epona kill
Tiffany qfs is out and get the kill
that's to kill death goes back in forces
aggressive pawn Leipsic hideaways and
guess what the hell get the triple kill
to get the quadrants to get the Penta
kill what on earth is going on
pentakill for the tori and duodenum porn
wins them this game our number one spot
goes to SKT bang and is 2015 msi Penta
against fnatic he didn't quite get to
bang female welcome back of the head up
all right gravy Kaiser comes down right
over training of the back lines of
thingy with a big absent 0 Marin is huge
literally because that wild growth booty
manages the catch major with his
ultimate the faker back you a fanatic in
big trouble double gilbert van ready
a triple kill and now gay telecoms to
fight that bingo for benefit
[Applause]
right those were our picks for the top
10 best pencil kills of all time which
pentakill is your favorite let us know
in the comments below thanks for
watching if you want more great content
be sure to hit that subscribe button